(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
- My name is Rui de Figueiredo.
I am a Emeritus faculty member
in both the Haas School
and Department of Political
Science here at Berkeley.
I'm also the Chair of the
Weinstock Lecture Committee.
Along with the graduate division
and the graduate counsel
of the Academic Senate,
I am very pleased to welcome
Governor Jennifer Granholm.
This year's speaker in the
Barbara Weinstock lectures
on the morals of trade.
Before I properly introduce
Governor Granholm.
Let me first take a moment to tell you
how the endowment supporting the lectures
came to the University
at California, Berkeley.
In 1902, Harris Weinstock
a well known business man
based in Sacramento,
provided the University
of California with a fund.
In honor of his wife Barbara
to support an annual public lecture
on the morals of trade.
The way he explained his motivations
in an article that was written
after the first lecture
in 1904, was as follows,
"Thus hope is in the air,
and there is a better
and cleaner day in store
for all destined to spend their lives
in commercial pursuits.
The thing to do at this hour
is to accelerate the movement
and to bring this hoped for day
as near to our own as possible."
The California University lecture ship
on the morals of trade is a
small effort in that direction.
Others who have delivered
the Weinstock lecture
includes consumer advocate Ralph Nader,
member of the British
Parliament Neil Kinnock,
Nobel Laureate Amartya Sen,
former U.S. Secretary
of Labor Robert Reich,
former Secretary of the U.S. Department
of Health and Human
Services Kathleen Sebelius,
and most recently nutritionist
and author Marion Nestle
and today's speaker is as accomplished
as the previous lecturers.
A few words abut today's
distinguished speaker.
A transformative politician,
Governor Jennifer Granholm served
as the former 47th Governor of Michigan
leading the state through
a period of unprecedented
economic challenge and change.
Governor Granholm became the first woman
to be elected as Governor
of Michigan in 2002
and in 2006, Governor
Granholm was reelected
with the largest number of votes ever cast
for Governor in the state of Michigan.
She served as Governor
of Michigan until 2011,
and prior to be elected Governor,
she was the state of
Michigan Attorney General
from 1998 to 2002.
After leaving public office,
Governor Granholm joined the faculty here
at the University of California, Berkeley
as a distinguished adjunct professor
at both the Law School
and the Goldman School of Public Policy
and as a senior research fellow
at Berkeley Energy and Climate Institute
also known as BECI,
and the center for Information
Technology Research
in the Interest of Society, or CITRIS.
In addition, she is a senior contributor
and many of you might
have seen her on CNN,
is the managing partner
of the Sustainability
group of Ridgelane,
is the CEO of Granholm Associates,
and serves on several boards
of start up companies and
non profit organizations.
She's also the co author of
the political best seller
a Governor's Story: The Fight for Jobs
and America's Economic Future,
and was co-chair of Hillary Clinton's
2016 presidential transition team.
She's an honors graduate from
the University California, Berkeley,
and Harvard Law School.
She has honorary degrees from
the University of Michigan,
Wayne State University,
Mary Grove College,
and Michigan State University.
She has received dozens of awards
for her leadership over the years
of public service.
She's also the chair of
the American Jobs Project.
A multi state research initiative,
on creating industrial
clusters in clean energy.
As a member of Berkeley's Work
in the Age of Intelligent Tools work group
she has been researching
ways to ensure that
automation and artificial intelligence
are not threats to equality,
but enablers of it.
Her lecture today will identify
some of the most interesting policy ideas
to address problems of displaced workers,
the skills gap, and resulting inequality
in the age of robots and AI,
or artificial intelligence.
It is truly a pleasure and
an honor to have her here
and for me to welcome Governor
Granholm to the stage.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- I am really very happy to
be talking about an issue
that has been so important to the Midwest,
and to anybody who comes
from a place or a family
where this issue about trade
has impacted the family wellbeing,
and we know in Michigan a ton of those.
I want to start with a story.
I am totally obsessed about this question,
about jobs, and how you
create jobs in America
in the global economy,
and because I was Michigan Governor
from 2002, two terms, to end of 2010,
beginning of 2011,
I was there at a pretty amazing time.
There was the bankruptcies
in the auto industry,
which were preceded by the bankruptcies
in the suppliers to the auto industry,
and when I came into office
at the beginning of 2003,
George Bush was president,
and at that time we were just coming out
of a national recession,
and in Michigan the old adage goes
that when the nation catches a cold
Michigan catches pneumonia,
because we make large products,
and those large products
don't sell during a recession,
but of course at the end of a recession,
when you come out, there's
a pent up demand for them.
Like vehicles.
So the notion is, when you
come out of a recession,
then you're gonna see a lot of jobs.
You're gonna see a lot more vehicles made,
because those factories
will start humming again,
and for politicians our
advisors were saying,
oh what a great time to be Governor,
because all these jobs will be created,
and we'll be able to
take the credit for it.
Fantastic!
In fact, at the beginning of a year,
when a Governor comes in,
you have to give a budget address
to the state legislature,
and the experts were saying
that by the end of my
first year in office,
by the end of 2003,
that you would see a huge
amount of job creation,
and that it was gonna be all okay,
because our unemployment rate at that time
was pretty high.
The end of 2003 comes around
and I didn't see a whole lot.
We didn't see a whole lot of job creation,
and I thought what's going on here?
Then I get a call from the guy
who is the head of the Michigan
Economic Development Corporation,
which is the public private entity
that helps businesses come to Michigan
and he says, Gov, we've got a big problem
and I said what is it?
He said there is a little
community in Michigan,
Greenville, and Greenville
has a population
of about 8,000 people,
and in that little town,
there is a huge refrigerator factory.
Refrigerator factory
is owned by Electrolux,
and they say that they are about to move
to go to Mexico,
and I said wait, wait, wait.
8,000 people.
How many people work in that factory?
He said almost 3,000.
3,000 people in a town of 8,000.
That's like a one company town
when you consider parents,
grandparents, kids, et cetera.
In fact, Greenville had called itself
the refrigerator capital of North America,
because in fact, Electrolux was
the largest refrigerator
factory in North America
in that little tiny town in Greenville.
When he said they were gonna go to Mexico
and I was the new Governor, I said no way!
We're not gonna allow this
to happen on my watch.
I'm Governor.
We're gonna bring my cabinet to Greenville
and we will make Electrolux
an offer they can't refuse!
Well not like a Chris Christie offer.
I know what you're thinking.
I'm talking about incentives
and stuff like that.
What Governors do.
We brought my whole cabinet to Greenville
and we went to the City Hall
which was probably a quarter
of the size of this room,
and we all sat around
this big square table
and everybody who was anybody
in Greenville was there.
Mayor, City Manager, the head of the UAW,
who represented the work force.
The head of the community college.
The head of the Chamber of Commerce.
Everybody, all the poobahs were there,
and I brought my whole cabinet,
and we all basically said,
Electrolux was there too and we said,
okay, we're gonna empty
our pockets full of chips
and we're gonna make a pile
and we'll slide our pile
and this is a metaphor.
Incentives in the pile of chips.
We'll slide our pile of
chips across the table
to the management of Electrolux,
and we will be able to save the factory
and save the jobs,
and inside of that pile of incentives,
it was really a list of incentives,
but it's on the list,
were things like zero taxes for 20 years,
and that was state and local taxes,
and we said we would help
to finance a new factory.
As you can see this is
actually the factory
and it was old and it needed upgrades.
The UAW said we're gonna
offer a level of incentives
and they didn't want anyone to know
how much they were willing to give
because they didn't want other employers
to be asking for those incentives.
We put these incentives on the table
and Electrolux takes
the list of incentives
and they go outside the
room for 17 minutes,
and they come back in and they say, wow,
this is the most generous
any community has ever been
in trying to keep jobs,
but, there's nothing you can do
to compensate for the fact
that we can pay $1.57 an
hour in Juarez, Mexico,
so we're going.
There's nothing you can do, they said.
When they said that it was
like a nuclear bomb went off
in that little community.
This is somebody leaving
on the last day of work.
This is the implosion of the factory.
This is the beautiful new
factory in Juarez, Mexico,
and I'm gonna go back
to him for one second,
because on the last of the month,
during the month that
the last refrigerator
came off the assembly line,
the employees had a gathering
that they called the last supper.
It was at this big pavilion in Greenville.
It was called Klackle's Orchard Pavilion.
It was an indoor pavilion,
and the whole community
went and I went too,
event hough I was not invited.
This was for me.
Can I just pause for a moment?
This story.
This has been my defining
moment as a leader.
This story, because it
was a failure on my part,
and it was so hard.
Back to the story.
I go to this dinner,
and I walk into the pavilion,
and there's 1,000 people there,
and they're sitting around tables
eating out of box lunches
and it's a sad band playing
or a band playing sad music.
It was probably a sad band too.
It was like a community wake,
and I go up to the first table,
and I'm not sure sure what I was.
I just couldn't get it out of my head
that I failed this huge
factory was leaving.
What was this community going to do?
What could I do as Governor?
I go up to the first table
and this guy stands up
and he's got tattoos
and he's got his tiger hat on backwards,
and he pulls his two teenage
daughters next to me.
He says Governor, I want
you to meet my daughters.
He said, look at them.
I have worked at this factory
he said, for 30 years.
I'm 48 years old.
I went from high school to factory.
My father worked at this factory, he said.
My grandfather worked at this factory.
All I know is how to make refrigerators.
Then he pulls his daughters in
and he puts his hands
on his chest like this.
So Gov, tell me, who
is ever gonna hire me?
Who is ever gonna hire me?
That question was asked by everybody
in the Klackle's Orchard Pavilion that day
and honestly it's been asked by everyone
of the millions of
people who have lost jobs
in the 70,000 factories
that have shut down
since the beginning of this century.
This experience, for me, seared my soul
I stayed till the last person left.
It wasn't just Electrolux.
I knew this was the
canary in the coal mine
for factories all over Michigan,
and it was just the beginning.
I can understand.
The president ran against globalization.
I used to campaign on it too.
NAFTA and KAFTA have given
us the Shafta, I would say,
and I was elected on
that because I get it.
I totally get it!
I completely get why people
feel like these vacant factories
that are sitting on main streets
all across the industrial Midwest
are permanent scars on
our soul and our identity.
Even if they've been imploded
and there's just a vacant lot,
everybody remembers,
oh that used to be the factory.
That's where we worked.
I totally get it.
I get why he focused on that,
but the question is, is it really now,
in the second decade of this century,
is it still all globalization?
Or is the other bad guy
for jobs, is it automation?
Actually about 13% of the job losses
for manufacturing have really
been about globalization,
and the rest are due to automation.
These two forces in this century
and obviously globalization
has been going on long before
the turn of the century
but this is just when I
of course experienced it
and that's why I tell that story.
The long term job killer isn't China,
as the president keeps saying,
it is really automation,
and then what do we do about that?
This graph is really instructive.
The first graph.
Sorry the print is so small,
but the first graph shows
manufacturing employment
in millions going down,
and manufacturing output going up.
Increases in productivity.
Going up despite losses
of jobs in manufacturing,
and there's all these shock
studies that are out now.
Automation to displace 20% to 25%!
Eradicate a third of America's workforce!
Machines will do half
our labor in eight years!
Ahhh!
We're gonna lose.
We're all gonna die!
We're gonna be taken over by robots!
What is gonna happen?
If I told that guy, in Greenville,
that there is an army of millions
of fourth graders who would
be willing to do this job.
Not for $1.57 an hour,
but say 40 cents an hour.
He'd freak out.
In fact, there's your army.
The army of workers that can do the jobs
for so much less money,
and Electrolux is now
delivering refrigerators
using autonomous vehicles,
so the drivers too, gone.
What are we gonna do?
What are we going to do?
There was this poll.
This is to the human side of this.
There was a poll that was
done after the 2016 election.
It was to blue collar workers
in the industrial Midwest
and this was the question that was asked.
Would you rather work full-time
in a good paying factory job,
or in a salaried office job?
What do you think people said?
Factory, yeah, by huge margins.
72% said I'd rather work in a factory job.
28% in a salaried office job.
The economy is shedding.
The exact kind of jobs
that these workers want.
There is real pain out there
in the industrial Midwest
but the question is where are the jobs
and where are they going?
We all know that tech is dominating.
The economy artificial intelligence, data,
the whole we see it live
it in Silicon Valley.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Tech is dominating the economy.
The sector is leaving the rest in the dust
if you look at the growth companies.
Obviously they're all tech companies
or most of them are tech companies,
and in fact, the top 10
tech bosses, billionaires,
own more wealth than 40% of Americans.
Not only are people concerned
that the jobs are going away
by the companies that are
coming out of Silicon Valley,
but there's also this
incredible inequality
that is being created as a result
of big tech, data, AI, et cetera.
The global average salary
of the tech worker.
About $135,000.
If you're in that sector,
you're doing great as a worker.
That's the global average,
but if you're not you may be left behind.
This income inequality.
The blue line going down.
The red line going up.
The top 1% is the red.
The bottom 50% is the blue.
This is not a new story.
You've heard it talked about,
but it's just to underscore the fact
that historic inequality is happening
at the same time as tech is dominating,
and as AI is replacing an awful lot
of these jobs that were historically here.
To me this stat says it all.
Despite having a great
economy, we're told,
you've got 40% of Americans,
who don't even have $400
in a case of an emergency.
40% of Americans, almost half the country.
You walk out and almost
half the people you see
will not have $400 in their bank account
in case of an emergency.
This stat however, is really troubling.
That 42% of Americans,
have not even saved
$10,000 for retirement.
There is a boom coming.
We've got a big problem,
that we have to deal with as a country.
This is the solution that is often cited.
In a number of think tanks, et cetera.
Is UBI, universal basic income.
Should we guarantee a
basic income for Americans?
Who pays for that?
Even though they may
not be working at a job
to merit that pay?
Silicon Valley in
particular is enamored this.
This is why I've got
one with the pitchforks
because there's some concern,
some realization that the tech industry
has created this income inequality
and they want to keep
the pitchforks at bay,
and UBI might be a way
to assuage the masses.
What is the answer?
We've been working here in this space
through our work groups
on artificial intelligence
and we decided that,
let's see if there's a way we can get
AI to work with us, for
us, instead of against us,
but let's not call it
artificial intelligence.
Is there a way to instead call it
inclusive intelligence?
How do you get that
technology to work with people
instead of replacing them?
That's the question.
Can there be this?
What tech hath wrought,
tech can help solve!
Potentially, potentially!
You've heard of Singularity, many of you.
Singularity is the notion that
we will be merged with machines.
With robots, at some point.
The robots are gonna take
over eventually totally,
and as Elon Musk points out right now,
you already are part cyborg
because every one of you,
is there anybody here who
does not have a cell phone?
Nobody.
You rely.
You don't have a cell phone?
Wow.
You are the cell phone.
Look you even get applause for that,
because you're the only
human in the group.
100% human.
What do these phones do?
They make you smarter.
They tell you where to go.
They have your schedule.
You can look anything up.
You are so smart, because
you have a smartphone,
that you already are
merging with the robot.
The question is, is there
a way to frame this,
that is a positive way, a hopeful way,
rather than a scary way?
Ken Goldberg who is here at U.C. Berkeley.
He does all of the stuff with the robots.
He heads the Robot whatever.
I don't even know what it's called,
but he has come up with a solution
or a theory of the case,
which is called, which
he terms multiplicity,
which means that instead of being replaced
that robots and AI can in
fact, enhance worker's skills,
and make them better.
Make them more valuable.
If the training is right.
If you can figure out how
to make it successful.
The thought experiment goes like this.
I'm sure many of you have seen this,
but since the ATM was introduced,
and people thought all the teller jobs
are going away as a result of ATMs.
Answer the question.
Do we have more or fewer bank tellers
since the late 90s, when
the ATM became ubiquitous?
Not saying.
We got more!
More tellers!
Since 2000, the number
of full time bank tellers
increased 2% a year,
but the entire labor force
only grew .6% per year.
Grew faster than the labor force,
or same thing with bar code scanners.
We are not going to have any real people
at the grocery store anymore.
You are gonna be doing the work.
Have we got more or fewer cashiers?
More.
I lead you into that, didn't I?
Yes, we have more.
Again, growing at an annual rate of 2.1%
when the labor force grew at .6%.
What's going on with this?
It goes back.
Remember the old luddites,
who threw the stuff in the loom
to make sure they still
had jobs doing weaving?
They didn't throw weavers out of work.
It's a classic case of, classic economics.
When you have something
created more cheaply,
people are gonna buy it,
and there will be more demand for it,
and so instead of you having a suit
that you would have paid your whole
annual salary for because
it was all done by hands,
now you can have a suit a day,
if you buy it at H&M,
because of the huge volume that's put out
and they're practically
throw away clothes.
The bottom line is there's more work,
more workers because of technology.
In fact, James Bessen who is
a professor at Boston University.
He actually had a study that he did,
of 317 professions,
where technology had been introduced,
and in this effort,
he said in all of the professions,
all of the occupations that
had technology introduced,
there was only one where the
actual job was eliminated.
Only one.
Do you have any idea which one it was?
Who said that?
You are on it.
Are you James Bessen?
Only one guy's job was lost.
It was the elevator operator,
and even in some places they still exist.
This is what his point is.
That employment grows significantly faster
in occupations that use technology more,
and this is true not just
inside of those occupations
but also externally.
Enrico Moretti, who also is
a professor here at Berkeley,
he wrote a great book called
The New Geography of Jobs.
He studied the impact of
technology on employment
around the employment.
He uses as an example, Apple.
The classic case, Apple employees,
12,000 people or something like that
in Cupertino at Apple headquarters,
but 60,000 in the economy around Apple
that aren't in even tech.
The presence of that technology
creates a dynamism that he suggests
technology has a great impact on.
I just want to focus for one second
on one example of a technology, a product,
that could be significantly impacted
negatively or positively by technology,
and that is the mother of
all technology platforms.
Which is the autonomous vehicle.
There are, you know how many drivers
that people who drive for a living,
what do you say, in the U.S.?
How many people drive for a living?
Five million.
Five million people drive for a living.
When you consider Uber, or taxi drivers,
truck drivers, et cetera.
Five million people.
That five million is like comparable
to the decline in manufacturing jobs
that we've seen so far this century.
The potential for losing jobs
in this space using autonomous technology
is pretty big right?
If you look at what goes
into an autonomous car,
this is just, you can't read it all,
but it just shows that
there's all of this stuff.
Whether it is sensor
hardware or battery storage
or engine efficiency or cybersecurity
or telecommunications,
connecting car to car, car
to grid, car to people.
Tires that have sensors.
You name it.
All of these products
that go into the car,
but what about what goes on around
an autonomous vehicle.
If you think about what businesses
could be created as a result
in logistics, or charging, or services,
or construction, or networking.
Let's just imagine for a moment
what that might look like.
You might have motels.
You might need to go to L.A. for a meeting
and you decide you're not gonna rent
a motel, a hotel, down in L.A.
I'm just gonna get in my
little autonomous vehicle
or I'm gonna call one up,
and they are gonna take me to L.A.
And I am gonna.
I don't know if I've got.
Can you see this?
This is a photoshopped thing.
I didn't do the Photoshop,
but I was chuckling as I
was looking at the picture,
because guy lying down, sleeping,
and his high heels and
sandals are over here.
His purple and pink.
It's very forward looking.
It's very gender fluid,
but bottom line is he's got his guitar.
You got your toilet.
You have your sink.
You wake up in Los Angeles.
You've paid $40 for the ride.
You're fresh.
You take another one coming back.
You could be working.
A motel on the road, literally.
What about this?
These pop up shops,
where you don't wanna
just buy a pair of shoes
through Amazon because
you want to try them on.
You just Uber up your pop up shop
and try your shoes on right there,
or I love the fact that the opportunity
for mobility for people
with disabilities is huge.
You can create entire services around
getting people with
disabilities from place to place
and configure the vehicles
to be able to serve them.
These artificially
intelligent transportation.
This is so interesting.
This says Alli.
This is a small little bus,
and the bus will pick you up,
and they imagine that because it has huge,
It's got a robot.
They partnered with IBM Watson,
and they will pick people up on a route.
They will connect you to your cell phone.
They'll know when your
laundry needs to be picked up
and ask you do you want me to stop
at the laundry on your way home?
They'll know that you like
that Starbucks Chai Latte
and they'll stop and ask whether
you want me to stop on our way home.
It's a little creepy, right?
Because they'll have
access to your information
and all of that stuff
about your personal life,
is a big issue around all of this,
but that's personalized
artificial transportation.
What about working out on the way home?
What if you could imagine?
I don't know if you could do a treadmill.
That would be a little bit dangerous,
but at least bikes.
Working out on your way home.
The stuff around it.
There's 20, no, there's 200 square miles
of parking in Los Angeles.
The whole city of San Francisco
could fit into the parking
lots in Los Angeles.
We have this massive housing crisis.
What if you don't need parking lots?
What do you do?
You could build housing.
Affordable housing,
and many of these housing
units they're talking about
you would get a unit and
you would have access
to the autonomous vehicles
as a service in the basement.
There would be a small
fleet for the people
who live in those particular apartments.
You would be able to access
them when you need them,
or rethinking the curb,
meaning that you wouldn't need parking.
You could see these cafes obviously
expand significantly and take advantage
of that extra space.
Rethinking the garage.
You don't need your garages anymore,
so the garage becomes the next Air BnB,
or the next small unit.
Your ADUs, et cetera.
Businesses who are thinking about
doing construction in small living spaces
since garages won't be necessary.
This, I'm hoping.
You think we can press?
I'm a little worried.
If we can press go on it.
Maybe not.
This is just a quick little.
This little delivery thing.
For any of you walking around campus
you see a version of this.
I just passed one as I was walking up
delivering little items to you.
It won't go on a freeway,
but it will deliver your groceries to you,
which is kind of cool,
and then, I love this.
Proterra makes all electric buses
and they're moving into
the autonomous space
and I love the fact that they are also
creating batteries as a service.
Meaning this as a service,
delivery as a service,
transportation as a service.
In this case, batteries as a service.
Another whole sphere of job creation
that you could imagine,
and batteries as a service,
they basically rent the battery out
and the buses put their own cap on it
and they service it separately
so thy don't have to pay for the full cost
of a battery up front.
It's kind of cool.
A cool business model.
The question is,
that's all just vehicles.
That's one thing.
Only 40 companies that appeared
in the Fortune 500 when
it started in 1950,
exist today, so there's all this churn.
The best example of the churn,
I think the most symbolic example is,
if you think about the
Gutenberg Printing Press.
When the Gutenberg
Printing Press came about
and gave everybody access to books,
all of a sudden, and
people didn't realize this,
you realize, oh my God,
I can't read the print.
I need my glasses.
A whole market for glasses came about.
Where did they get those glasses?
The Isle, been to Venice?
The Isle of Burane has great glassmaking
and they put glasses upon glasses
and instead of just now,
instead of just glasses,
they had telescopes, and microscopes,
as it was all coming from
the Gutenberg Printing Press.
We don't know what's gonna happen.
What other kinds of jobs or businesses
could happen as a result of
the autonomous vehicle or
any other AI kinds of things,
but the question for us all is,
because we don't know, how
do you prepare a workforce?
In that case.
How do you prepare a workforce
to be able to be flexible and adjust
to the different changes in the economy?
I'm gonna give you five quick ideas,
and these are not comprehensive.
These are just five ideas that people
have been talking about that
I think are interesting.
One is, this comes from Europe,
guaranteed subsidized trial employment.
The Swiss example of having
interns and apprentices.
We just don't do that well here.
We have got to get over our phobia
about copying what other
countries do that work
because it really does work.
In Germany they have a
system called Kuzerweit
when times are bad the
government helps to subsidize
the employment of the
people so they stay on.
They don't have to pay unemployment.
It's a creative way of thinking about how
the public ends up working
to incentivize or
disincentivize employment.
85% of Swiss apprentices find
a job within three months.
This is a company that's
closer to home out of Colorado.
I pulled this up because
there's a lot of innovation
that's happening in the tech space
about how to train people
and this one, 87% of apprentices
called the Techtonic Group
successfully placed in tech jobs.
They do coding, and what they do,
is they take people who
haven't even gone to college
who maybe are really interested in coding
and who may be coming from
a disadvantaged community
and as a result, Techtonic has clients,
that they go and do software projects for
and they bring their apprentices to them
and the clients can decide whether
they want to keep this person on or not
and as a result 82% of the apprentices
from these diverse populations,
or 87% are placed.
82% of these people who are replaced
are from diverse populations.
The average salary is $75,000.
That's a really great program.
We should take that to scale.
It makes a lot of us think about
why do we spend all of this
money subsidizing unemployment
when we could be subsidizing
instead, employment,
because what would we spend.
We spend $24 billion annually
on unemployment insurance.
What if we flipped that and take derisked
for the employer.
Allow them to hire people
during a training period.
Have the government subsidy,
instead of paying for unemployment
paying for that employment
and then have it phased down
once the person being
trained is fully hired on.
This is a different way to think about it.
Idea number two is to create
data driven training modules
for critical skills.
AI is fantastic because it allows you.
It allows the system to
know where you're at.
How much you know.
How you learn.
The current workforce training programs
that we have in the U.S. are terrible
and they're antiquated
and they don't work.
There's a bunch of studies about this.
The evaluation of the trade
adjustment assistance program.
$11,500 per person is paid.
Only 37% of people are employed.
Working in the targeted
industries four years later.
That's a really crappy percentage.
The Workforce Investment Act, same thing.
It appears possible, the
ultimate gains from participation
are small or nonexistent,
and we spent a lot of money on it!
The overall programs themselves
failed to evolve with the global
information based economy,
where technical know how trumps muscle.
What do we need to do about this?
Data can make training great again!
In the classroom, if you
look at AI driven learning,
it has been enormously
successful in the classroom.
Where the kids, you take
someone where they're at
and you have them learn in
ways that they best achieve.
So it's both how much they
know and how they learn it,
that AI can help, and you
can see here 214% improvement
through learning software,
compared to other students,
for those who took
their training that way.
The Navy has piloted this
digital tutor program
in the workplace.
This is a pilot through
the Department of Defense.
It improved problem solving performance
by 94% over classroom training.
We should be taking this stuff to scale.
All the way across.
We're so darn slow,
in how we take advantage of technology.
Rather than be victimized by it.
Idea number three is to
pay people for their data.
I happen to love this one,
because it's very cool.
In this regard, think about it.
Data has become, as they say,
the new resource, the new oil.
All these companies making
huge amounts of money.
Off of your data.
You're on Facebook.
You're giving them all
sorts of information.
They are so happy that you
are providing that to them
because they can then
sell it to advertisers
and make a huge amount of money off of you
and you are just giving it to them.
Not granted you get a
personalized experience
in exchange, and the question is,
over and above that
personalized experience,
who gets more out of the aggregate data
that we're all giving to
Facebook, Google, et cetera,
and this goes beyond
just those experiences,
but if you think about data
that is being accumulated through
all of our devices.
It's a lot of data,
and it is occupying a greater
and greater percentage of the economy,
and if this is being addressed
in California and Europe
have decided that you
are gonna own your data
and that you have the ability
to say what somebody
should do with your data.
This is the General Data
Protection Regulation.
Of Europe, and California's just starting
to experiment with this.
They're not paying people for their data,
but they are starting to say
you have a property interest in your data
and Mark Zuckerberg testifying,
actually said every piece of content
you share on Facebook, you own.
You own it, and you're giving it away!
Actually me and Chris Eldrin
who is a student here,
we did a piece on this for CNN
that Facebook owes you money.
There's a whole group.
There's a movement here.
Facebook users unite.
Data labor union launches
in the Netherlands.
Should we treat data as labor?
Moving beyond free.
What if people were paid for their data?
The notion is instead of
a universal basic income
where you are given money for just being,
maybe you could be given, being paid,
for the amount of content you put up there
and I used the analogy of
the Alaska permanent fund
where in that case in that state,
everybody gets a check.
Last year it was $1,600 because
of the natural resources that is beneath
the land and the water.
The oil and gas natural resources.
What if we considered
data to be a resource
that requires some kind
of shared, profit sharing
from the companies that are using it
to make enormous profits?
If AI, this is a Professor out of Yale
who is doing a lot of work on this.
If AI represents 10% of the U.S. economy,
he estimates that paying people for data
would raise household
median income by $20,000
which is a bigger increase
than the postwar era.
That's assuming that you get to 10% of AI,
in the economy,
which actually I think is a
pretty conservative assumption.
How would this work?
A lot of questions about
what that would look like?
How do you value the data?
Who negotiates the data for you?
People are talking about
these data negotiation
intermediaries that would actually
do the negotiations on behalf of people
to the companies.
How to enforce your standards.
What is the role of government?
You look at the analogy of, for example,
Spotify pays a micropayment, a royalty,
to those who have their
intellectual property
listened to in music.
Small micro payments.
You create an account,
where little bits of
micropayments might go
and you wouldn't take the whole thing.
The company still has to be profitable,
but the amount of data of yours,
that's being used to
create enormous profit,
the question is do you
deserve a little share
of the profit from those companies?
The next one is, I happen
to love competition,
and I think that from a
public policy perspective,
creating competition is a really cool way
of getting policy adopted.
Creating a competition for a
data driven workforce training
is I think a neat way to go.
There's you see the SunShot
from the Department of Energy
which was a competition
about getting solar cheap.
The Race To the Top.
The X prize were all competitions.
In fact, the Workforce
Innovation Opportunity Act,
right now we spend $10
billion to do training.
$10 billion.
If you took that $10 billion
and created a competition,
oh my God, it would blow the roof off.
I use the Race To The Top For Education
as an example because what happened when
the Obama Administration came in
and they wanted to raise
high school standards,
what they did was to say hey states,
here's $3.4 billion.
That $3.4 billion we'll
allow you to compete for it
but the price to enter
is that you have to raise
your high school standards to essentially
be a college prep curriculum.
$3.4 billion.
48 states raised their standards!
Just on the basis of that little carrot
that was out there.
$3.4 billion is not a little carrot,
but to states, all 50 states,
that's a big incentive.
If we have $10 billion being spent
for ineffective workforce
development training programs
right now, and you put that out there
as a competition among states,
I am telling you, you
would get massive response,
by both the private sector and governments
who want to work in ways
that would achieve great
workforce training outcomes.
48 states.
Who were the two states
that did not compete?
Do you know?
Texas.
South Carolina.
Those were the two,
and you know what the
frustrating part was,
we all competed, and in the first round,
only a couple of states got the money.
We did not in Michigan.
I was so bummed,
because I cannot tell you how hard it was
to get the legislature to act to do this,
but nonetheless, you could
formulate this in a way
where everybody gets a little piece
if you have a $10 billion fund.
Last one, is the idea of these
new workforce arrangements
where people are creating
employment through Uber,
through an app, through
Task Rabbit, et cetera.
How do you create portable
benefits for them?
How do you create an environment
where they are covered in some way,
because right now they
have got no benefits.
The notion of course that
a college graduate today
should expect to have 30 different jobs,
three separate careers,
over their 60 year working lives,
and this arrow up here.
1995, 2005, to 2015.
57% increase in the rise
in alternative work,
where you are on your own
probably using an app
to be able to connect
with potential customers.
94% of the net employment growth
in the U.S. economies from 2005 to 2015,
94% have occurred in these alternative
work arrangement spaces.
That's a huge increase
and we haven't done anything about it,
and here's the kicker is that 80%
of independent contractors and freelancers
preferred alternative work arrangements
to standard employment.
They prefer that kind of flexibility,
that kind of lifestyle.
They can choose when to work,
but they are completely on their own
when it comes to retirement,
when it comes to healthcare, et cetera.
What do we do about that?
In the old world, everybody
works for something
like working for the
University of California.
You got your employment relationship.
You also had contractors
who had individual
relationships with people
who were hiring them.
These independent workers in the middle
are going through an app.
They really are totally a
different work arrangement.
They're unable to organize.
They're unable to collectively bargain
for wages or benefits.
They're not protected by civil rights
of anti discrimination legislation.
They're unable to receive benefits
without being classified as employees,
and this is the battle
between traditional employers.
They don't want to take
them on as employees.
They don't want to have to be responsible
for all of those benefits.
How do you do this?
We've gotta create a system
where you have a safe harbor for employers
to offer portable benefits, without I-Ws.
Those are independent workers.
Without being classified as employers.
They should be able to offer some kind
of series of accounts,
where they could do the tax
withholding, social security,
and Medicare contributions,
unemployment insurance,
retirement savings,
create learning accounts,
while allowing that person to
be a free agent essentially.
What's the world that that looks like?
There is this portable benefits issue
is being discussed all over the place.
It's being discussed in Europe.
It's being discussed
through legislation here.
Portable Benefits for
Independent Workers Act.
There are state experiments in California,
Washington, New Jersey, New York.
Just a quick example of
this from another country,
is that the government of Singapore,
has given as a benefit to people
these individual learning accounts,
which go with them wherever they are.
They started out, the
government actually paid
$500 for every worker over
25 years old in Singapore
to be able to get educated as
a life long learning account
and you can take a class
in flower arranging
or cybersecurity.
Whatever is it.
They just started doing
this two years ago,
so there hasn't been an
evaluation of the program yet,
but the bottom line is portable benefits
have got to be a solution
for the workforce of the 21st century.
Those five ideas.
Subsidized trial employment.
Data driven training.
Paying people for their data.
Competition.
Flexible portable benefits,
and here's the finish!
Who is gonna get displaced
workers into good jobs?
Who will sustain the middle
class in the digital era?
Who will save us on the planet
from death and destruction?
Who can ensure AI will
be a force for good?
Is it President Trump?
Or our next president, whoever she is?
Is it Elon Musk or Bill
Gates or Mark Zuckerberg?
Is is Gavin Newsom?
Or is it Oski the Bear
and Berkeley brain power?
(audience applause)
We have an opportunity to do
a few questions and answers.
If anybody wants to
engage in a discussion.
- [Man] I wondered what
happened in Greenville.
Did those people get jobs?
- Well, here's what
happened in Greenville.
Throughout my entire two terms as Governor
I worked with the city to try to get them
to become a sustainable community.
Green Up Greenville.
We brought in solar manufacturers,
and because of the fact that
in China they were dumping solar panels
in the United States,
the factory that we brought
in ended up closing.
It was even more agony for Greenville.
What ended up happening
is a Walmart came in
and so people now are working
at half the wage at the Walmart.
Not everybody obviously.
A lot of people took retirements.
Just a follow up.
One more on it.
In Greenville, because
of the Electrolux factory
there were all these suppliers in the area
to supply the factory,
and those suppliers also closed
when Greenville went away,
and the ripple effect in this community
was really very huge.
We decided after, as part
of my initiative as Governor
that we would create something
called No Worker Left Behind,
and I stood up at one of my
state of the state addresses
and said all right, the
first 100,000 people
to raise their hand,
we will pay for full
community college tuition.
We'll give you $5,000 per year.
$10,000.
You have to be trained in an area of need,
and we had identified what
those were in Michigan.
Like nursing and tech, et cetera,
and we would pay for your tuition,
and we had within months,
the whole program was subscribed to.
I went back to the federal government
and said instead of this TAA,
and workforce can you
just give me flexibility
and we could add more people to this.
We added another 50,000 people
to be able to get trained in an area
that they wanted to get trained in,
but here's the kicker on it,
is that a lot of people
who are like 48 years old,
like the guy I was talking about,
they don't necessarily want
to go to a community college
and sit next to a 21
year old and do calculus,
when they can't even
remember whether they.
They don't remember
percentages from high school.
This wasn't something they took.
This is why doing training,
in a way that respects where people are,
and takes them to the
next level at their pace
and in their way, is a
really important strategy,
and in a lot of ways
we had the union halls
be open to be doing the training,
and bringing training into them
because they were more
comfortable in that setting,
but training has to be flexible like that.
- [Man] If you wanna come up,
and just wait to ask the question.
- [Woman] Thank you very much.
These are some really excellent ideas.
Most of which I had
never thought of before.
I need to process a little bit,
but one of the things I wanted to ask you,
was could some of these ideas,
not be compatible with something
like a universal basic income,
because for example your Alaska analogy
essentially was like a
universal basic income.
That is what the does.
It doesn't actually depend on their skills
or their age or their
training or the employer.
I just wanted to ask,
are these substitutes,
or could they be
compatible with something?
- The paying people for data
is sort of like a universal
basic income concept.
Similar to it.
In the Alaska situation,
people get compensated,
because they own the state,
and the question is what's the analogy
for a country where you have a state,
like in Michigan, we don't have
huge oil and gas resources,
where maybe we would have to think
of a different way of doing it,
and the question is,
is there a way to do it,
that doesn't cause people's
hair to catch on fire
because you are redistributing
mass amounts of income
through tax increases,
and so the question is,
is there a different way of looking at
a universal basic income,
which guarantees people some dignity.
The other thing I would say though,
there's a lot of pushback from people
who feel like I don't want
to just be given a check.
I want to have there be
an exchange for my input.
Whether it's data, or my work, my sweat.
Whatever it is.
That's the pushback you get.
I think from people on the left even
who are saying, UBI, the concept is okay,
but you want to respect the dignity
of people who want to be able
to be engaged in employment.
- [Woman] Thank you for your talk.
Would you mind talking about the fact
that I believe there are millions of jobs
in the manufacturing
sector in this country
that go unfilled over
long periods of time.
I think especially since
the end of the recession
and I'd like to, I don't believe
that you've talked about that
and where's the problem,
and how do you solve that problem?
- Yeah, I would say
that there is definitely
a mismatch of demand and
supply in certain areas.
Especially with a low unemployment rate.
There's a lot of jobs
that are going unfilled.
A lot of the work in
manufacturing now though
requires a level of skill
that you wouldn't have needed in the past,
so it requires somebody to
have some kind of certification
to do the CNC, the machines,
that actually do the manufacturing.
It's sophisticated.
In fact, in one of the last years
when I was Governor.
We cut the ribbon on a factory
that was an engine plant,
where they weren't hiring anybody,
who didn't have a college degree,
because you had to have people
who knew how to operate the robots,
and how to maintain a robotic line,
and that's where manufacturing has gone.
That's why we're seeing
some of the reshoring
is because it's cheaper to have robots
and fewer people,
but the people who you hire,
they've got to know how to operate.
It gets back to the question of training.
If there's a gap, it's a training gap.
Here's the problem,
is that when you've got a
very technology driven job,
whether it's a coding job,
or working with robots job,
the employer expects the employees to come
fully trained up.
They're not often willing to take the risk
on training someone themselves,
which gets back to this question
about can the government
offer a subsidized
training period, so somebody
can learn those skills,
where the employer doesn't
have to pay fully for it
and then transition over
to the employee training.
Right now they don't.
They aren't taking that risk
on hiring somebody who doesn't have
a computer engineering
degree from Berkeley
and that's cutting out a
whole swath of the country
and only a third of the
country have college degrees.
What are we doing for them?
- [Man] Good evening.
I have a question regarding taxation.
As we move toward a knowledge economy,
and a data driven economy,
what are the appropriate ways to capture
that revenue stream,
and where do you see
that going in the future?
- Well, this is a really
interesting question.
My husband Dan who is sitting there
was just talking to me
about that this morning.
You want to share your idea?
No, okay.
(audience laughing)
But it's a really important question,
because we have a tax structure,
that especially with the latest tax plan
that really drives all the revenue up.
Benefits the people at the top
and the people at the bottom
are left without anything.
Think about a structure
that's much different
that really does allow
people to make the money
that they need to make and earn the income
they need to earn,
but gives a slice of that
to the folks at the bottom
because this disparity
that has been created
by the structural changes in our economy,
is not benefiting everybody,
and it's a redistribution
question that you asked,
and whenever you talk about
redistribution in Washington DC
people's hair really do catch on fire.
The issue is can we elect people
who are not afraid to say, hey,
who are we as a society?
Are we gonna create a safety net?
Who are we?
Are we going to allow people
to be sleeping under bridges?
Because we haven't cared for them.
What kind of community
do we want to create,
and one would expect
that in the 21st century,
people would say hey,
we share this planet.
We share the air, as
terrible as it is today,
but we share the salaries
for the firefighters
who are out there fighting this mess.
We share responsibility for the roads
that you drove on to get here.
We share responsibility for
this fabulous University.
We should be sharing a
responsibility for one another
and keep that safety net intact,
and people once you start to talk about
taking something from someone,
that's when people freak
out until they need it.
Until they need those services.
You would hope that you hold
one end of the safety net.
I hold the other.
We hold it to make sure
that nobody falls through.
One day I may need it.
One day you may need it,
but in the end we hope that
we could create a world
where nobody gets left behind.
Where we are like the Marines.
Nobody gets left behind.
We're all going.
We're not leaving anybody back.
Why can't we create a world like that?
Why can't we talk about
sharing a little bit more?
It's a great question.
Maybe you should run for office.
- [Man] You mentioned a couple times
and I kept hearing the
word union and labor.
Where does union fit
into the private public
relationship with training going forward,
because it's always been
where people have gone
when they needed training.
- Exactly, and it's a great moment
for the unions to think about their role
in this digital economy.
One could imagine that
there would be a data union,
or one of the existing unions
would take on the negotiation,
for your compensation,
for your inputs on data.
You could imagine a world where
the unions become the
brokers of great skill.
Rather than people see
unions in these silos,
but when I think about
the UAW for example,
which is the union I'm most familiar with
from Michigan, United Auto Workers,
they were the place where
the auto workers went
to get trained workers.
They were the place.
In a 21st century, why not think about
those portable benefits for the workers
who have alternative work arrangements.
There should be a union or a negotiator
or some entity that is pooling
people's desires together
and has a common face to Uber or whomever.
To be able to negotiate for them.
I think the unions absolutely can have
a new role if they look
as well, at themselves,
as transitioning in the 21st century.
Not just building on old models,
but looking to the future.
I think that they could.
Some of them are doing it.
Some of them are not.
- [Woman] I find it interesting
that you mention Walmart.
Something is very broken in our country,
because workers at Walmart,
a lot of them are on food stamps,
because they're not making a living wage.
The Walton family has this
enormous enormous fortune
where they decide how to spend the money.
It's not just looking to the government,
it sounds like looking to the government
to expect something
more humane from Walmart
and companies like that.
- It's interesting, isn't it?
That there isn't more accountability,
at the level of ownership of companies.
Like we, you probably
have a retirement fund,
and you have some shares of stock.
I don't know if you have Walmart of not
but the bottom line is, a lot of times,
we don't exercise any
power as shareholders
to insist that the
companies that we invest in
behave in a way that would make them
be part of the community,
and leading as well.
We identify as shareholder.
Fudiciary responsibility of shareholders
to maximize profits,
and that's the only thing,
that a CEO looks to, is maximizing profit.
Maybe we should look at
GDP in a different way.
Maybe it should be about
wellbeing of the citizens
of the country.
Rather than just wellbeing of
the pocketbooks of the CEOs.
I wish I had a good answer
for how to fix this.
If I were Bob Reich.
I would tell you the answer,
but I will leave that to him,
because I know he spoke
at the Weinstock series.
You can find him anywhere, as you know.
It's a great question about how to hold
these companies to account for their role
in the creation of a more equal society.
- [Man] There are companies
that are trying to
evaluate and give each
person a unique identifier
with a blockchain and then
evaluate the preferences.
One of my friends is starting that.
He's already raised $200
million for that one.
- Really?
- [Man] Yeah, it's a big thing.
They used to run blockchain for IBM.
This is Silicon Valley.
- The blockchain is going to.
- [Man] Well it's a unique identifier.
Every unique identifier,
what I want to do is
have it DNA sequenced.
That way it can't be modified,
and the other thing is
with neural networks
you can actually set up a system
which would optimize
the gross value of a GDP
evaluates all the workers,
what everybody's worth.
That's probably what you should do
because the biggest problem
you have to worry about.
Forget Europe.
It's all China, AI.
We're in a race to basically
stay alive against China.
Whatever we have to do to optimize
our economic situation,
basically thinking like this,
AI will basically optimize things
in a way we've never done before.
That's what the big game is,
and we want to optimize as a society.
The value of society,
and you could do that
through neural networks.
You can have economic feedbacks.
MIT tried to do this in the 60s.
Of course it would fail,
because there wasn't
enough data information,
and it was too sophisticated.
Now we have models to do that.
That's what we should
really do as society.
Thanks.
What do you think?
- Here's what I'd say.
I think that tech can solve a lot of this,
and we are so advanced in neural networks
and blockchain, and the
next generation of whatever,
that we should take advantage of it,
and have it be part of lifting all boats,
but we don't do that right now.
That's not how it's viewed right now.
The question is how does
that get programmed?
I often think about this in terms of
the engineering schools in the country.
In the medical schools,
people take a Hippocratic
oath to do no harm.
We don't have that kind of.
There's not that kind of ethos
in many of the engineering schools
and what they're building could
be benefiting ends that
don't serve our needs
and so you wonder if it can start earlier,
and have an ethos be built
into the education system
and into whatever oath they have to take
to become an engineer,
that there's something that
there's a responsibility
to the society, to the community,
and using that technology,
to be able to lift all boats.
I think is a great thing.
Yep.
- [Woman] Hi.
- Hi.
- [Woman] I'm actually a
student studying data science.
- All right!
You are gonna have a job in a minute!
If you don't already!
- [Woman] I actually would like to know,
it's very clear that technology
is evolving so rapidly.
An exponential rate almost,
and I was wondering how would people
entering the workforce,
who are already in the
workforce evolve with it?
- That's the question.
Is I think I put it there as an example
these lifelong learning accounts,
but I think we should take
that seriously as a nation
because if you're already in,
you're gonna be, bless your heart,
you're a millennial.
You're gonna have this great job,
but at some point maybe 20 years from now
we're gonna need to sharpen the saw.
Maybe 10 years from now.
Maybe five years, and maybe every year,
you need yo go back and learn some more,
because it is evolving so fast,
and how do you have the ability to do that
without accessing some kind of,
some ability to pay for some up skill.
You might have an employer
that's willing to do that,
but you might not too.
I think everybody should
have the opportunity
to continually learn
and to have a lifelong continuous
portable learning account
where you can go back and
upgrade yourself is critical.
It's one of the ideas that I think
some are talking about,
but you all who are gonna
be taking the baton,
of leadership in this country,
you can make it happen.
You can run for office.
Were you not excited about all of these
great young people who
were elected on Tuesday?
Yes!
(audience applause)
Diverse group.
I'm so excited.
- [Man] I wanted to
extend a really heartfelt
thank you to Governor Granholm.
- You are so welcome!
Thank you all for coming out!
(audience applause)
(upbeat music)